now i had some reports from people who
feel very weak when they drink too much
water especially when they're doing
fasting and i want to talk about why
that is
it's basically a deficiency of sodium a
person is going to feel very weak if
they don't consume enough salt and i
recommend sea salt so there's all sorts
of things that can make you deficient
with sodium
number one not consuming enough sea salt
and of course when you're fasting you're
usually not consuming anything except
water and the more water you drink the
more you dilute the minerals including
salt and sodium so the combination of
drinking more water when you're fasting
is a bad combination you always want to
consume sea salt if you're fasting our
bodies need minimally three and a half
to four to five grams of sodium that's
roughly between a teaspoon and a half to
two teaspoons of sea salt every single
day also if you're doing low carb you're
going to require more salt than if
you're doing higher amounts of
carbohydrate that's simply because when
you're in a high carb diet you're going
to retain more salt than when you're in
a low carb diet
now the other thing that can create a
sodium deficiency is consuming large
amounts of potassium so if you're doing
electrolyte with a lot of potassium and
you're not doing enough sea salt that
can throw you off too especially if
you're doing all these other things like
fasting so don't forget about the sea
salt now the more stress you go through
the more salt you're going to need
because when you're pumping a lot of
cortisol you lose sodium salt is needed
as a part of the stress response now of
course if it's hot outside it's summer
and you're sweating and you're
exercising you're definitely going to
need more salt and if you're on a
diuretic or an antidepressant you're
going to need more sodium if there's
liver damage if you have hepatitis or
you have a fatty liver
or you have cirrhosis or you have kidney
damage because you're a diabetic
you're going to need more sodium which
is interesting because a lot of times
you're told to avoid
salt if you have those conditions and
lastly you can lose salt if you have
diarrhea or you're vomiting so these are
all factors to consider if you're
feeling weak
you could be deficient in sodium
one quick way to find out is just to
start consuming more salt and see if you
feel stronger
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others